Clio is the king of the afterworld and
from the second that he joined his
Titanic friend kate winslet on the red
carpet to the parties into the night
while entertainment tonight's cameras
were rolling it was a big night for Lyon
of course host Chris Rock who came out
and wasted no time diving headfirst into
the diversity issue some say he pushed
too far I say it was vintage Chris Rock
funny edgy and exactly what the night
needed I thought he was amazing
fantastic alright more than 34 million
people tuned into the 88th Academy
Awards which named spotlight the best
film of the year brie Larson Best
Actress and of course the man of the
night Leonardo DiCaprio
after five acting nominations Leo
finally gets his gold Leonardo DiCaprio
the revenant star shared a sweet hug
with Kate Winslet and on the red carpet
you can still feel their chemistry
almost 20 years after their movie
Titanic what did you guys say to each
other
oh I just asked you with who was okay
and then actually I noticed that he had
one little eyebrow so I just put it back
into place for him so you got him
together
but no one was happy over Leo
then his proud mom or Merlin oh I was so
happy you have no idea and I loved the
fact that he had such a big audience to
make the statements that he did climate
change is real let us not take this
planet for granted I do not take tonight
for granted thank you so very much
I always be feeling what right now very
very happy he's thrilled it has been an
incredible journey for Leo AG was there
at his first Oscars back in 1994 he was
nominated for Best Supporting Actor at
19 for What's Eating Gilbert Grape
being nominated against these people is
like being with like the top
heavyweights Leo picked up his statuette
at Oscars and grading station
and right after Leo brie Larson
patiently waited for her award free
Lawson through three one for Best
Actress and although she was relatively
unknown heading in to award season she's
been around Hollywood since she was a
kid
it's so exciting it's absolutely
incredible I've watched us on TV every
year since I was seven I think so to be
here as a part of history
we inspected the nameplate and posed
with a boyfriend
Demi Lovato helped debris celebrate and
the actress looked relaxed enjoying an
in-n-out burger and her sneakers but
there was a touching moment that you
didn't see on the live show that really
speaks to Brie's character
it happened after Lady Gaga performed
her nominated song surrounded by
survivors of sexual assault till it
happens to you after the powerful moment
brie hugged and thanked all of the
survivors I was trying my best to tell
their story and I hope that I did right
by them Gaga reflected on her own
struggles as a victim of sexual abuse
posting a tribute to her man Taylor
Kenney quote he loves the survivor in me
he stood by me all night long proud and
unashamedly that's a real man Gaga and
Taylor shared a kiss at the Vanity Fair
party along with a lot of other hot
couples
after four months of dating Granum Blake
held hands and made their red carpet
debut at the magazine's afterparty
Stefani performed at an Oscar viewing
party at Spago she dazzled in a sheer
scarlet Ioannina couture gown an inside
Vanity Fair Jessica Biel and Justin
Timberlake got cozy at the event catered
by Bhushan